[موسيقى]
الميزة أود أن أقول أنك لا تحتاج إلى أي
إجازات إذا كانت لديك خطط في المنزل
بعد يوم مرهق، فقط أشعل شمعة
واجلس في الغابة، هذا أكثر من
كافي، فأنت لا تريد أي شيء آخر في
الحياة، مرحبًا،
هذا فايشا  أعيش في دبي ولدي
حوالي 120 خطة في غابتي الداخلية
وخططي هي أصدقائي
وعائلتي وهذا يجلب الكثير من
الطاقة الإيجابية في حياتي وفي منزلي كانت
المشكلة الرئيسية معي هي أنني
كنت أعاني من العقم  لقد
بدأت المشاكل تؤثر علي عقليًا
كثيرًا، لذا حتى بعد العمل، إذا عدت إلى
المنزل، فلا يوجد شيء بالنسبة لي مثل
البكاء الدائم أو أنك لا تفكر في
أي شيء فقط فيما ليس لدينا
ولكن بعد أن بدأت أعمال البستنة، أنا متحمس
للمجيء  في المنزل لأنني أريد أن أرى ما
الجديد الذي يحدث في حديقتي كل يوم،
سيكون هناك براعم جديدة بعد
ذلك، كلما مررت بفشل التلقيح الصناعي،
لم يؤثر ذلك علي أبدًا لأن
النباتات تعلمك الصبر والأمل
ألا يتوقف الناس عن النمو أو الخسارة
الاهتمام بالبستنة إذا قتلوا
نباتًا أو نباتين، فيجب عليهم الاستمرار في المحاولة
وشراء نباتات جديدة والبستنة هي أحد
الأشياء الجميلة التي يمكن لأي
شخص القيام بها.  إلى الصيف واشتريت
الكثير من النباتات خلال ذلك الوقت لذلك
اعتقدت أن البستنة ليست جيدة، لا أستطيع القيام بذلك
لأن قتلك يشعر بالحزن الشديد
عندما تقتله
[موسيقى]
هل أنت خائف، هل أنت خائف،
هل أنت خائف؟  حسنًا، لا بأس، هذا أمر
وقح، هذه الفتاة هي حيواننا الأليف منذ
العام الماضي، لذلك كلما أسقيت
كلما أبلغت عن خطتي، فهي مهتمة
بأمري وكما أنها تحب كل ما
نفعله بالخطة، فهي تستمتع بكل
جزء منها
كل يوم يبدأ بمجرد استيقاظي أنا
هنا أسبوعيًا أحاول التحقق من جميع
الأواني حتى لو وجدت أي وعاء جاف
أذهب للسقي ثم قطف الأوراق
إذا كان جافًا
بدأت Instagram على ما أعتقد عام 2016 لأنني
أحب التصوير الفوتوغرافي وأحبه  التقاط
الحركة هو أحد المنصات
التي يمكنني عرضها، أعتقد أن الناس
بدأوا يحبونها وبدأوا في
الاتصال بي يسألونني ماذا تفعل
بخططك، كيف تبدو خططك دائمًا
جديدة جدًا
اليوم إذا سألني أي شخص مثل عدد
الأطفال لديك  لذا فإن إجابتي هي أنه
ليس لدي طفل بشري ولكن لدي أكثر من 120
خطة وملاحظة من شركة Sunco بأن أطفالي
أجانب